hey guys it's Wednesday and lacking any
kind of annoying sound-alike intro I've
just decided to say hey thanks for
watching it yeah thanks for doing that
I'm Dan this is game spot news we happy
few the unsettling survival horror game
that's been in early access for a little
over a year now now has a solid release
date you might remember this one from
Microsoft's 2016 a through press
conference where we got our first
glimpse of a protagonist refusing to
take his state required joy pills before
attempting to escape from an underground
bunker since then we happy few has been
available via early access on stayin and
game preview on Xbox one
today develop a compulsion and else the
title will receive a full release
including a physical version on April 13
of next year on all platforms yes even
ps4 the for release will include a
campaign featuring three moderately
terrible playable characters each with
their own reasons for giving up on
artificial happiness the game will
retail for 60 bucks and if you pre-order
you'll get a bonus jolly Brawley pair
assault weapon there will also be a
limited edition collector's set that
includes a bunch of really cool stuff
like a replica bobby mask lamp alarm
clock and vinyl album but not a copy of
the game publishing gearbox explained
they're not including a copy of the game
will so that early access players can
purchase the collector's editions
separately destiny two's out really soon
and it's coming to PC in October via
blizzards battlenet recently some
destiny content went up for sale on
Steam leading users to believe it might
arrive on Valve's platform but it turns
out that's not gonna be the case silver
the in-game currency you can buy with
real-world money recently became
available for purchase on Steam bunchy
community manager David each day was
quick to address the mistake over on
Twitter saying destiny transactions on
Steam were made available in error all
purchases will be refunded manually by
valve sorry for the confusion
he followed up with her apply to a fans
saying aware with blizzard and their
plans to release destiny 2 on PC
anywhere up posted on as announced
previously destiny 2 will be available
on PC viable is battlenet platform the
online service that operates games like
overwatch and Wow if you're interested
in checking out how the game runs on PC
you can check out a new 4k trailer for
the game right here on GameSpot or take
part in the PC beta which kicks off on
August 28th for those that have
pre-ordered let us know what you think
about
really being available on battlenet in
the comments section below
finally crackdown 3 has been delayed
until a spring of next year meaning it
will no longer launch alongside the Xbox
one X the action shooter was originally
set to arrive on November 7 on PC and
Xbox one
but it appears plans have changed
Microsoft Studios GM Shannon Loftus told
polygon we're very excited about
crackdown 3 and so are many fans and so
it's a difficult call to move the
release date however we want to make
sure to deliver the right game with the
right quality and at the right time
crackdown 3 is a hugely ambitious game
and we want to ensure we deliver the
right experiences all the way through
every part of the game
whether that's campaign co-op
multiplayer or our competitive
multiplayer mode wrecking zone getting
the balance right between the three
modes is important and we are going to
take the extra development time to
ensure that clock decided that the dev
teams will use the extra time to focus
on the visual polish to ensure the game
is completely immersive you may remember
crackdown 3 was originally scheduled to
write in 2016 so hopefully fans of this
one can sit tight a little longer that
is everything we got for you today
thanks so much for sticking around and
do let us know what you thought of
today's stories and we'll see you thing
to him tomorrow I'm gonna get a new wave